ben shapiro editor in chief of the daily
wire.com been two hours she was perched
on that statue what did you think of
this stunt
I mean it's idiotic they then had to
evacuate the entire island because they
decided to do this stunt the real issue
with the stunt is not that someone is
pulling a public relations ploy in order
to get media attention people do this
sort of thing all the time the point is
is this actually productive for her
cause like let's say that you were hurt
you were she and you you you thought
that you were going to bring attention
to this particular cause the best way to
do that to climb up on the Statue of
Liberty and annoy everyone in the
country did she win over any supporters
with this no I mean the only people who
are into this or the people who already
support her but but I guess that's where
we are in the country at this point is
that everybody is attempting to rev up
the base more than they are attempting
to win over people in the middle and
that's particularly true for folks on
the left you think the louder they
scream the more people are gonna win
over it seems like precisely the
opposite is true
seems the louder they scream the more
people are looking at the Trump
administration and saying well at least
they're not shutting down the Statue of
Liberty on the 4th of July she was
taking advice from Michael Moore as you
just heard him earlier we we have to in
his words put our bodies on the line to
stop Trump is is this what the far-left
movement movement is pushing for at this
point I mean there's no question that I
think that the heart of the far-left
is is with this particular part of the
movement there the Maxine Waters
shot people down in gas stations the
let's go to a restaurant and shout
Christian Nielsen out of a restaurant
the a--let's let's badger elaine chao as
she comes out of as she comes out of
dinner this is this is where the left's
heart is and this is the real problem
for the Democratic Party because Schumer
and Pelosi are sitting there saying guys
we're alienating a huge swath of the
country and the hard left is saying well
you have no heart you don't have the
passion well when the passion is not
united with it with the leadership of
the Democratic Party it's pretty clear
who's gonna lose and it's not gonna be
the passion the passion is going to win
there's a wild sweat a wild shift to the
left that's happening thanks to the this
thus far left part of the Democratic
Party it doesn't bode well for them in
in future election cycles if they
continue it which I suppose is fine with
me
well obviously the 28-year old Democrat
Socialist brought a lot of attention to
this the hill a piece in the hill this
morning progressives poised to shape
agenda if Dems
take back house is that the case I mean
there's no question that
they believe that the all of these
spirit is with the Bernie Sanders left
of the movement now what's really
fascinating is that there was sort of a
gap between the intersectional left and
the Bernie Sanders left a lot of the
people on the intersection will let
people who thought about identity
politics and race they said that Bernie
Sanders wasn't paying enough attention
to issues of race and sexual orientation
and sex that he was almost too focused
on socialism Ocasio kasnia Cortes is
doing a good job of bridging that gap
because she is an intersectional
candidate obviously she's she's a
minority ethnicity and she's a woman and
she's also preaching Bernie Sanders
socialism and that's why the party is
seeing her is the sort of great uniting
figure even though she is as radical as
radical can be you know you wonder if
they risk turning off some of their own
voters going this far to the left but it
is something that we're watching and
clearly the world was watching us as
that woman scaled the Statue of Liberty
on Independence Day yesterday ben
shapiro thank you